gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus
we've played the Leo IG with the crowd
shows are selling out and you can get
your tickets at rugarbage.com see you
there
[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there welcome back to
everybody's new favorite podcast this is
are you garbage oh yeah it's that little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find it at the group to
be classy yeah aren't you just a big old
piece of trash I'm your hostage Foley
coming at you on a rainy day out back
here at hoodies in the new edition she's
over at the chiropractor getting her
back blown out okay good for her okay my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is the CEO of are you garbage
heading down to the shore in a couple of
days to reclaim the title of Mr Neptune
2005. yeah Forum on the boardwalk be the
guy with a Sam's Pizza in his mouth give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan what's up
gang thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate view subscribe
on iTunes full video available on
YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking baby and obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage gang
it's a [__] party over there we just
hit 10 000 patrons thank you enough gang
we love you to death and speaking of
loving you to death happening nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
give it up for Toby T-Bone McMuffin over
there Toby McMullen everybody hey what
up boys what up T-Bone hey we got a guy
in here at the top of his game came in
here sweat looking real nice dude you
got a little poof going on there I
wouldn't be throwing shade he's got a
little bird's nest up there well you got
to give people the real feel that hair
looks like it's attached to your
headphones
I need a little Tresemme over there for
this [__] humidity
hi caramba oh frizzies gang we couldn't
be more excited to have our incredibly
and I mean incredibly special guest here
with us again today he's [__] family
at this point man about a million times
you know him you love him got a brand
new special coming out on a major
streaming platform out right now Soup To
Nuts give it up for Mark Norman
everybody look at that normando I was in
here that was amazing and can we call
this garbage anymore this place is this
is new money baby yeah this is crazy
they're gonna come and take it so
shortly this is what happens when
dirtbags hit the lottery is they they
get a full-size Knight of armor yeah you
get an R2D2 bar yeah
I tried they wouldn't let me do it
remember when an arcade game was uh the
the peak oh
that's my dude that is my claim to fame
I cannot believe I actually own an
arcade machine five grand to fix it yeah
in our age level the movie big was the
yeah the Pinnacle of of luxury that
trampoline indoors was there anything
better than that bunk beds skateboarding
on the hardwood uh-huh [__] a weird
lady Coke machine yeah that's all right
that was my name in college
yeah the only thing about that apartment
in big I would be scared you'd fall out
the window with that trampoline those
big Windows yeah why do you think that
joint's going for these days holy [__]
that's gotta be Soho or Tribeca that was
like a huge Loft right huge Loft oh yeah
that now that's got to be about 80 grand
a month easy easy talk about a real come
up that first night he was in that
[__] [__] and they were shooting
each other outside
got the job right yeah shout out to Big
that was an all right movie great movie
that was back when you could get laid
like because now that would be a big old
big old controversy oh sure the 14 year
old [__] the lady that was hot though
as a kid who was like eight I was like I
gotta change he didn't bang her though
remember she stayed on the top oh that
[__] do they oh yeah later on when he
stays at her place I feel it
she was a real cougar and she took
control do they bang and big
oh it's all big bang stuff
a great show as well there you go buddy
good to see you yeah ma'am hey hey good
you're right down the road you were
doing the old uh you're all over the
place I'm hurting man we did fully
loaded I did uh some gigs in Boston then
I flew to Theo's pod then I did Zanies
in Nashville then I got back yesterday
and did four shows of the cellar are you
ever gonna throw it in low gear not even
neutral are you ever gonna just be like
I don't need to be in nine states and
one kick off a European tour what are
you talking about yeah I can't stop I
mean Why Stop Now where we're young
we're gay we're running around we got
all the energy this guy's amping me up
I'm in yeah let's go do a show do you do
anything cultural when you when you're
over there in Europe oh yeah I'm gonna
bring the lady and we're gonna really
find all the the American restaurants
you know see if they're different hit
the KFC hit the McDonald's I gotta tell
you you lose weight in Europe they don't
have the preservatives and the the
queefs the portions are different yeah
it's not like five plates it's very
small and modest yeah yeah so you can
have fun you can eat a bunch and still
drink but you come back I'm like I
didn't put on 50 pounds I feel all right
I know it sounds lame to me okay got a
lot of poison the poison makes it good
but it ain't but it ain't good for you
well you try to order in the language of
the country you're in or will you you
will yeah that's funny you do the weird
accent you're saying English words but
with a Spanish
yeah
yeah exactly but do you speak anything
do you speak can you get a little French
in yeah I grew up from New Orleans which
is like you know everybody's a little
French there it's like being Jewish in
New York you know but uh yeah but I got
a little bit of it's fading it's fading
fast my parents put me in French
immersion uh which is where you learn
math in French science
beer battered yeah wait what's French
immersion that's where you learn
everything you emerge it's like a French
school yeah really but it was half
French and it was a public school so it
was half of these nerdy French kids and
then like Street kids wait that's where
you went to high school no that was a
grade school really so I started in
kindergarten learning French no [__] you
went through a French
Elementary School half French half Urban
yeah Noir
holy [__] that's a [__] yeah yeah
he's got a wild did you have kickball
and [__] like that yeah we had
everything I mean recess it went back to
you know you were in New Orleans yeah
you were yeah you weren't in Paris yeah
it was a mix we all mixed together
playing tennis on grass courts or
anything like that hey yeah uh drinking
mint juleps sear sucker the whole thing
but
I had to get out I had to get out it was
two it was too French okay I didn't know
that and they sent you a regular
Elementary School no I just went to the
black side what do you mean in the
school it was half the school itself was
half and half yeah you could do French
immersion you could just do regular oh
really yeah whoa so I went to regular no
kidding yeah it was it sucked man those
French kids must have been tortured oh
man but the girls were real [__]
early I mean the armpit hair sucked but
they were like you know six years old
smoking we wanted to ask you
um he got the house now yeah right kind
of kind of sure you said you said the
lady was really taking charge as far as
putting together are you living in there
now no no not there it's a money pit
it's all demo and all these come
guzzling Nazis come in there they got an
engineer everybody's got a goddamn
clipboard there's 15 guys do you think
you're hiring one guy that guy needs a
guy everybody's got a guy you gotta have
some scumbag from the dob with a phone
on his belt you know he's got to come in
and go oh oh this is all I gotta go this
is all unsafe we gotta tear all this
[__] down you're like come on man and
luckily my contract is like this Irish
guy from Queens he's like oh [__] this
[__] we're gonna do it how we do it you
know and then he went to Italian
emergency apparently I can't do
accidents
thank you very much
um oh but uh yeah so he's like don't
worry we'll we'll just work around and
we'll just tell him it's gonna be fine
do you have anything that you're putting
in that's like special are you excited
about like Hey listen babe you can
decorate the whole thing I just want
this one yes I I have this there's a
seller in this thing I'm talking
medieval [__] you know with the arched
brick cement floor dead rat cobweb and
she's like I'm never coming down here
and I said good I'm gonna take it and
I'm gonna put a [__] twister uh Matt
down there I'm gonna get a couple of
Weights pull up bar I'm going full
Commando really are you gonna make it
nice you're gonna leave it as is and
just kind of real Bare Bones kind of
that's your dojo type thing no I'm gonna
make it nice I'm gonna try to make it
like you know get a couple neon bar
signs and a cool room somehow that's
nice for him yeah Michelob Ultra what do
you think yeah okay maybe a little bit
okay for lack of a cornier word yeah a
little bit I try not to use that term I
know it's bad but yeah it's that's my
gonna be my spot I'll put some mics down
there you know uh one of those weird
blow up balls that you can do sit-ups on
okay you know you're an odd guy you
gotta have your space how about a
section on the big screen TV oh we'll
get that too uh what about what about in
the kitchen you said she was handled but
are you doing like uh you're doing the
nice stuff hiking stainless steel stuff
because it's not like your your big
purchase big house this is where you're
Landing probably forever knowing you
probably live in house couple of Rugrats
but uh she's going all in with the the
color swatches and that she's working on
handles doorknobs light fixtures sconces
what the [__] the sky that's what they
start getting you when you start talking
about what the hardware yo what color
the screws are nice oh I'm terrified the
island has it does it have a wine cooler
or not I'm like oh God it's just
cha-ching that's gotta be a couple of
box all right
um but yeah yeah this is gonna be it's
gonna be tough but uh that's why it's
taking so long it's been a year and a
half we're supposed to be in is there a
deadline is there is there a Finish Line
in sight but they're kicking around it
keeps moving back they keep saying uh
Hey by August then that's not gonna
happen hey by Thanksgiving so now we're
at Christmas so I'd love to get a tree
in that [__] could you sleep in there
now or no no no no no Plumbing jammed up
yeah yeah there's already a a squatter
in there you know it's like not done
wait is there really a squatter in there
there was no [__] the guy called me he's
like I just kicked out a dude he was
doing heroin in the cellar I said that's
my man cave
see if he wants to hang out yeah he
already got buddies in the neighborhood
look at you right right you go ever go
over there and just stay at like walk
through and like oh this is mine this is
crazy completely all the time really
like [__] I finally achieved this that's
why and this is something anything are
you walking around like [__] [__] what's
this car no that's 10 G's that's 5G it's
kind of nice knowing it's not done
because it's all up you know it's all
hope right now so I like this part it's
like the vacation once you're at the
vacation you're in Hawaii going I still
hate me you know I'm in Hawaii but I
just don't hope you still have oh my God
what it could be exactly yeah so I'm
Dreaming I'm walking around in there and
you think you'll be a different you once
that's done you'll be like I'll be the
guy in my you know who has sconces and
does ab workouts in his man cave right
right we're gonna get the paper
delivered you can start getting the
Times breaking the times I'm gonna give
Girl Scouts money I can't wait to be
part of a neighborhood that really yeah
yeah I would have joined the the
neighborhood watch you know steal from
the bodegas yeah you name it
um in the bathroom are you getting uh
his and her uh uh sinks well we got we
got this the place is pretty big so
she's gonna have her own bathroom which
I love she uses my toothpaste this is my
lady for you
I don't want to make this we don't have
to turn this into the view but uh she
she doesn't think where she'll like use
all the toothpaste and then I'll I have
hidden toothpaste because she won't go
out and buy it so I'll go buy the
toothpick and then she just uses all
mine
is this weird no I kind of do the same
thing okay because I I had to do it
today I was out of what's at the sink
right and it's my stuff I have my stuff
at the sink that I use and then I have
to use I start once that's low
it doesn't get replaced so I'll start
using the stuff I take on the road
all right here's my little head stash
that no one knows about yeah now she
finds she finds a stash oh she's she's
your dab kit going through all the [__]
you know she's like what's the Bluetooth
for and you go don't worry about that
but
I got heart trouble yeah I gotta thin my
blood but my ankles are swelling up on
the flight but yeah so uh so I can't
wait to have my own bathroom but I'm
gonna lock her out I'm kind of very much
the same I like my own stuff very kind
of just the way I like it without people
intruding on my stuff she did this one
the other day she threw out my towel I
have a gross towel and she threw it out
and I go what am I going to use now
she's like well that towel had to go and
I'm like well there's no replacement
yeah that was the towel so she doesn't
get a new towel so I gotta get a new
towel what is your what so that that was
really your only towel at the house I
had one tell of a minimalist Jesus this
guy's Bare Bones man and it was black
too so who knows was on that thing you
know because the White Tile you can see
you at least see the smudges I figure
when you guys got married and she and
you guys moved in that she would have
went and got like you know about a set
of towels and stuff I thought women just
had that program but she's different
yeah
and I was gonna ask you you don't you're
not taking your toothbrush out of your
uh your shaving kit your travel bag
there's a travel toothbrush and your
regular toothbrush right yeah yeah but I
still have the regular one hidden
because she'll use it when she loses
hers
the toothpaste I only have one brush
brush wait you have a toothbrush or the
road and the house no I only have one
really one that's great how do you do
that what do you mean so you have to
keep altering you're packing like a
[__] no I do it I got I can walk out
that door five seconds same it's okay
yeah grow you I mean you're acting like
it's like it's a rifle or something it's
a [__] toothbrush you got two
toothbrushes Right Toby no well you
don't do the road really yeah he comes
out yeah I open all the shows you only
got one that's nuts I I don't bring it
because I just get one from the lobby of
the hotel
what those toothbrushes stink yeah right
there you can't clean a shoe with that
thing he also he also brushes his teeth
in the kitchen sink most of it oh yeah
that guy huh yeah yeah when you're in
here we're at airbnbs a lot and there's
five or six of them we travel heavy on
the road we take a crew out and uh
before the show the bathrooms are
occupied with six people getting ready
oh to go to the show but not at home no
no I'm spitting on the dishes no no no
no no no no not at home but when you're
in there taking your Jurassic Park shits
I gotta go somewhere
what do you want
uh wait you're almost them
I don't know I'm confused you're on the
Jose
just took my I took the I took my sixth
shot today rocky road yeah
got my new pen ready to go right here in
the thigh you go thigh stomach uh arm
three a day no or man of his size yeah
you better need a bigger boat I need an
elephant gun going through like a box of
cards I've never seen a man take four
barrels
I'm still eating you gotta hit him with
him
one of those rigatoni and me wow man
honey those empties good for you man
sounds great he's doing great yeah it
feels good I mean I don't want to make
the sad but you feel a little shame you
know in the 80s you had to just lose the
weight now we can just take one of these
uh knees to feel shame about it no I I
was I started to feel bad like I started
to like not like physically not feel
well yeah yeah like make sure you're
nauseous no no no no I'm saying before
that of course before I was taking the
outside I was getting so fat and so
bloated that I was just starting to not
feel well and that's the first time that
really ever happened oh really in my
career as a as a fat pig wow because
we've been talking about it
we have a monthly meeting where
everybody everybody airs their
grievances now you just like it started
you bend over and this and that and
everything hurts so now that the
weight's starting to go down a little
bit it I feel 100 you look better he's
down he's not a good clip I'm yeah thank
you what about the six
uh not that many heaters okay that much
and we're not drinking that much yeah
we're kind of the endocrinologist said
that it kind of takes you know they'll
want to to booze away a little bit the
road's tough obviously you know the food
and the you know the food and the booze
yeah especially we do the road night
night now we do three nights three
cities oh so that's really running and
gunning so it's like not even at a hotel
for the weekend of like I can try to
make it better wait I should feel guilty
like I'm cheating am I cheating I don't
say I'm juicing you're Jewish
which I'm happy about because at least
you're alive it's a good thing sure I'll
tell you what does suck about it is I
love to eat you don't say I know wait
what no the cookies on the table
that's all those in big pens
help yourself the water if you want one
um sit down with like a rigatoni Olive
Vodka some garlic bread mozzarella
sticks french fries the whole little
thing sure let's sit and watch Seinfeld
for like four hours that's the luxury
that you can't can't do it you start
feeling sick after like you know like
like half a dish wow yeah have you
thought about pushing through and just
eating through this thing
not shifting gears
burn it out
I tried for like the in like I think
like after the first week I like tried
to like really like eat like a like a
full thing and I couldn't do it oh wow
so it works oh yeah yeah no it really
works side effects
um I've been having real bad heartburn
oh no I don't know if that's a thing and
a bit of an attitude
I can't get it up grab it at pigeons in
the streets trying to eat them
all right well [__] good to have you
back we missed you thank you buddy 2.0
yeah right now this is the least amount
of breathing I've heard on this thing
yeah your headphones cut off this
episode is brought to you by better help
gang I've been losing it guys going
bonkers yeah maybe even more than ever
more than ever I'll be honest with you
more than ever I'm losing it right now
he was just next to us before we started
recording Google and not good stuff yeah
I'm falling apart but you know what I
did what I told you a couple weeks ago
reached out better help I know back and
forth a little bit you gotta jump in
baby talk to somebody and even just that
it started it started to feel better it
started to help gang if you're dealing
with something reach out to better help
talk therapy is very important uh you
could do it from the Privacy you're on
home you don't got to go to an office
you can do text you can do chat you
could do anything they got you covered
and if you don't have a specialist in
your area they could set you up with a
licensed therapist it's good stuff gang
if you get the pressures building up hit
that release valve a little bit just
just reach out to them say what's hit me
up let there be be your map with better
help baby visit betterhelp.com garbage
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash garbage baby do it the
Link's in the description click it and
they can't control your life do it okay
let's talk about pretty litter oh baby
not only your spokesman
client player president over here buddy
got it in the litter box right now the
birds away I've been having to use it
and deal with it it's fantastic it gives
you a little flexibility yeah because
it's real real good stuff it's not the
craft that they use to throw on the
school floor when Kevin hurls in the
lunchroom it was chilly day this is this
is high-tech stuff here's the cool thing
if there's anything going on with the
cat the crystals turn different colors
I'll give you the heads up you know I
tried it out
rainbow
uh with different color crystals like
the big man said pointed out pointing to
problems like UTI's kidney issues and
more you can easily keep track of your
cat's health and act at the very first
sign of illness of course with the pet
you don't know you can't ask them you
can't be like hey he's your Tommy here
you got a headache you hung over
whatever you gotta just [__] you got
to be sifting through her poop and stuff
this this lets you be hands-free a
little bit that actually happened to us
her pee was it was a funny color and we
tasted weird you
a lime
um saw a little something that was
concerning we took her to the vet turns
out she has a little thing in her inner
urine okay so we had to put her on
special food little urinary tract
situation okay special food and some uh
and some uh supplements okay that's
great there you go you get ahead of it
pretty litter has the best litter uh you
can use you'll probably save me two
three grand I know go to
prettylitter.com garbage and use the
code garbage to save 20 off your first
order gang uh that's pretty litter.com
garbage code garbage to save 20 off your
first order pretty little.com slash
garbage code garbage terms and
conditions apply Seaside for details do
it
all right let's do some cues yeah let's
get into some questions guys as you know
uh when you join the old patreon over
there uh uh we will answer your answer
your garbage question on the air it's
just the best way to do it we get a lot
of requests emails DMS the whole nine
yards but patreon gets first crack at it
because they're the homies uh this one
I've never even [__] thought of in
all the years we've been doing the show
and it's rightfully so you just got
married as well uh this is from Thomas
how much tongue was in your wedding kiss
oh that's [__] that's a great [__]
question did you go for it did you go
heavy I did I should say I don't know
how bad this is I was on shrooms at the
altar because uh that's an awkward
moment you're married yes yeah there's a
bunch of comics there I felt weird so I
popped a couple of caps takes the edge
off exactly just a little micro though
you weren't blasting off in outer space
no I mean at one point she looked like
Artie Lange you know but uh I just uh
yeah I took the edge off and I think I
did a couple Spears a little yeah just
to get in there crack the door yeah you
breach the entry exactly exactly I
basically Rim jobed her mouth okay just
a couple uh Dill Spears uh-huh I think I
did a little I've been to a couple yeah
I definitely did a little you know nice
respectable amount of tongue I've been
to somewhere like they [__] oh yeah
we're at like an Elks Lodge or something
and they just go at it yeah that's wild
going to town sometimes it's an ass grab
yeah
I don't know if we asked you the last
time you were here well I think it was
before you got married it was right
before you got married did you do the um
did you do any like the old uh things
that they used to do at weddings like
did you do the garter belt where the
where the best man takes the garter belt
did she throw the bouquet I never got
that one I always thought it was creepy
she threw that okay she threw the book
that's normal that's dad pulling that
[__] down yeah I thought it was the best
man it's like the best man or something
which is like perverse isn't it yeah and
then somebody throws that over or
something like that yeah I remember I
think my stepdad had one hanging from
his rear view mirror dudes every one of
my older cousins had one of them hanging
from an IROC Z in the 80s from some
wedding they were at it's a big deal you
got to sniff it I would touch it when I
was by myself what do you got on that
T-Bone the groom will remove the Garter
from underneath the bride's gown with
hands or teeth gross whoa and toss it
into the crowd uh the Garter is similar
to the bouquet toss The Bachelor that
catches the Garter is believed to be
married next that's what it is it's for
the guy yeah I remember I remember other
dudes yeah other dudes doing it or put
it back on her or something I had a
wedding where the bride had a tongue
ring maybe
you know it's a bad sign in a wedding is
kegs ah what the [__] I was at a wedding
once in in Louisiana I've been there
yeah I went to one of Philly yeah it was
real real and was so it was August and
it was outside it was so hot and dude
but you were just like I just want a
cold beer and after this and you get in
there and it's just sitting it's like
lukewarm water and [__] because the ice
is melted yeah I haven't seen a keg of
beer in 25 years that's crazy it takes a
good normally you show up somewhere you
see a keg like this is going to be a
good time totally I love a cake but at a
wedding you're like this won't last this
marriage is doomed or when you got to
make your own it's like the plastic uh
vodka handle with like Cokes
that's called a wide open bar yeah
there's a squirt back there yeah exactly
it's all flat a little Fresca Ah that's
tough did you do the open bar you did
the open bar wide open and we're just
asking top to bottom we had like eight
bar stations so you couldn't miss
didn't have anybody waiting no waiting
and we had a a raw bar if you want to
talk bars so we had the oyster shuck guy
you know it's Louisiana so you gotta dig
into the seafood down home baby shrimp
the oyster the crawdads we had it all no
kidding everybody's fingers smelled
you gotta love when a booze bag throws a
party because they're like
I everybody's got to be able to get a
drink at all I don't want any jam up you
go to because sometimes you go to a
wedding where that's not important to
the people and you're like it's like an
afterthought oh we're only here to get
[__] up yeah I don't really care that
you got married yeah give me the booze
when there's that one or two bars and
the line is [__] out the door oh the
word it's like a Walmart the Friday
after Thanksgiving it's a tough look
it's Black Friday yeah you're waiting
[__] an hour to get a [__] drink
yeah cause and then they start busting
your balls like you can only get one yes
get the [__] out of here you know you
got to drop that that finsky in there
yeah yeah first time I make sure you got
to be rude with it the first time of
course polka stanza paper money you know
did you do a brunch the next day yeah I
didn't make it really I was so banged up
the mushrooms the the booze the dancing
and was that cool Hey listen I'm not
gonna make it yeah she went it's okay it
was a lady thing and then you know I I
hit him for lunch I met him for lunch
nice but the brunch was it like nine
come on was everybody there was it just
the girl it was mostly the gals and a
couple of gays nice well that's good
yeah that show she's cool yeah she was
super cool she got it we didn't even
bang the wedding night because I was so
wrecked yeah me too really I called my
wife a [__]
I said get your hands off me you [__]
that's a beautiful start
hey it can only go up from there you
know what I mean it's true you're
calling me yeah
I don't know what to do I don't know do
I hit her man
holy [__] that's a great question right
there I'll tell you yeah I never thought
of that
um all right this one this one's from
our boy alex tanelos out there in
Beantown shout out shout out to him uh
have you ever ordered food at a strip
club yes I have once it was during the
day which is never good I had a meeting
in a strip club a meeting yeah me and
cotton had a meeting we were gonna do a
show I remember that come by we'll have
lunch wow that's like a mob move yeah
well I did uh you ever been to eggs and
legs no foxy ladies in Rhode Island no
they do a big breakfast buffet with the
with the ladies that's all right I could
get behind eggs and legs it's great is
it a buffet yeah but it feels a little
off those eggs are a little funky yeah
yeah get out of here don't put those
under a black light no some cigarette
smoke and a pube that's all you can
queef yeah there you go but I did a gig
in Springfield Missouri the Blue Room
yeah yes we've done it sure so the guy
who owns it's a bit of a he's a cool guy
but he's a kook sure and he goes I'm
gonna take it the best steak we gotta
get the best steak and I go great let's
get a steak it's like three in the
afternoon strip club okay so he thought
this was hilarious but the steak was
like a [__] Firestone you know it was
a good year it was brutal and uh he was
like huh funny right steak and [__]
and I'm like this sucks it's four in the
afternoon the women look like this guy
and uh the steak's horrible uh-huh you
good looking kid T-Bone don't don't
different but as in a in a garter belt
in a G-string that ain't that ain't what
you're looking for he's got a big old
nog on them that's true I've heard
they've heard stories I've read Vlogs
yeah uh we were just actually talking I
forget where we were talking about you
have the infamous story of uh get the
lobster or the get the [__] filet
mignon or whatever and then the guy
charged you for it oh yeah we were just
talking about my funny farm in
Youngstown Ohio I'll never forget it
that guy rooked me I got Bamboozled not
if there's a guy who doesn't like a
surprise check it's you yeah you got
that right
um hey Phil what happened to me I would
have like all right we'll figure it out
I'm not happy about it but you probably
well I was also I was an open mic I was
dead broke just getting out there I was
breaking even barely remember those days
yeah so I don't know if I told it before
but I got there and the guy's like hey
you gotta get the swordfish and this
wine pairs well he kept up charging me
and I was like hey I'm living like a
king this is great I live in Bushwick
you know I'm finally out here on the
road Showbiz and as a young comic like
that a free meal this is the coolest
thing in the world you think you're
working the you're in Vegas you were
featuring no I was headlining you were
headlining there's a c Club yes I'm
kidding D you know I got the the napkin
in my shirt I got the fork and knife out
I'm putting corn on the cob in my pocket
you know I'm really going in for this
meal I got the fish and the the
appetizer the bread
dessert wine I think it was like 280.
my check was 500. so man brutal [__] is
he goes what are you kidding we need the
money oh [__] all right smart move we
were we did it somewhere recently I
think that's made of where it came up we
got hit with the comics get two drinks
each that's it or something that's crazy
and we were like you know there's like
four or five of us in the green room and
it's like we're like all right we're
going [__] heavy it was one place
that we went to in the beginning when we
first started touring and the Green Room
had a hundred dollar limit that's what
it was we hit that in about 10 seconds
10 seconds yeah wow well that ozembic
will help yeah
but it's always one comic who [__] it
up they go hey we had smokes
he ran that thing up and he had an
Entourage so thanks a lot Stan hope we
were at uh
I think we were talking about this in
Cleveland hilarities because they roll
out the red carpet that's a great Club
hilarities is a great Club beautiful
Club a lot of food yeah delicious you
can go there for breakfast they're like
come on in real yeah I don't know if
everybody knows that but the place is
all right that's also like kind of like
old school like they should you're at
that big bar they lock the doors they're
like cranking cigs and everybody's
hanging it's like a feels like they're
shining a little bit
all right right no murder yeah but good
time that's a great Club yeah
um all right let's see here this one's
from Cole ten dollar homie never had a
question red is a garbage or go to
McDonald's for just fries because you're
cooking burgers at home yeah that's
crazy wait wait can you translate that
they're cooking he's cooking burgers at
the house okay like for dinner but once
McDonald's fries so goes just gets fries
from McDonald's as the side that seems
nuts to me I like this guy that's
slightly up there with Roy wood Roy wood
said if he had like a Burger King
McDonald's and something else and a
Wendy's close together
he like on his way home he would hit
McDonald's for the fries Burger King for
the burger and Wendy's Wendy's for a
Frosty and then go home and have his
meal that's amazing yeah that's like too
much for me well now you got Uber Eats
you can just get all that [__] coming to
your house you don't have to do the
stops yeah I don't I have a thing
against getting new that fast food I
don't do it either I'm with you I'll do
food like regular like food whatever
especially on the road but fast food
Uber Eats is just not it's a new low
Toby you okay with it oh I do it all the
time really all the time it's because
everything's a ghost kitchen now so it's
the only thing you can get consistent
and then you can really hate yourself
what's a ghost kitchen so in New York
they make like if you go on like Uber
Eats or whatever and it says like TJ's
Pizzeria or TJ's you know Wing Stop that
place doesn't exist it's just a kit you
can't go to TJ's it's just a kitchen
whoa or it might be just enough it might
be like some Diner that agreed to sell
whatever these people's things are it's
just all branding there's no real a lot
of them there's no real or in the
kitchen is like seven the kitchens TJ's
wings and then it's TJ's pizza then it's
Gary's pierogies right whatever so we're
getting catfished yes 100 I don't know
where it's coming from or where it's
going yeah yeah where are you ordering
in from uh I'm a diner I do the diner
because you can get a little everything
you go the diner experience stinks yeah
are you cooking are you in you and the
bird cooking at the house she cooks a
lot which is great so like you go home
you have dinner sit at the table uh
are you sitting on the couch little
little table little couch sometimes I'll
light a candle we'll do it up little
footsie uh but it's usually the couch
like hey let's put on uh you know the
last of us or some some uh what is that
one uh the abducted
abducted in plain sight that's what he's
watching while you're eating so now I've
got a documentary yeah but they just
made it into a series and it's hot
really yeah he ran through the whole
family is that your show yes that was
that's a crazy
[__] from the dad
[Applause]
yeah so when you're eating uh you know a
little rib eye it's a pretty good living
you guys have shows that you watch
together oh yeah like not her shows not
your show shows that you both want
totally she goes off with the Bachelor
and 90 day anal whatever and then I go
with my uh scary YouTube [__] are you
you are you watching comedy
World videos I hate all of it but I have
to keep up it's so funny too because
it's a lot of like our friends there are
people like we're all at this stage now
where it's like oh there's that guy I
know and there's something about I'll
take a peek at it you gotta peek because
you want to know what's up with your
friend but it's like watching soap
operas with people you know yeah it's a
lot of drama I hate the drama but uh if
it's on there I'm gonna watch it keeps
you coming back well it's also weird
because YouTube knows you so well if
you're on YouTube TV or whatever it's
like oh it's like I mean I get ones for
normal like Mark Norman does so and so
and I'm like I'm one click away from
just peeping this rule I get you guys
should all think Joe list was on so that
pops up with Sarah you know and so we're
all we're all intertwined I know it's a
family that algorithm's got our number
baby they say the algo knows you're gay
before you do yeah pretty wild because
like if you hang on like uh looking at a
thumbnail with a guy without a shirt on
or whatever long enough right all that
like [__] minuscule data he was doing
push-ups
this is an algorithm goddamn rats
sometimes you throw a couple like uh
scapegoats in you know you're like oh
let me get this puppy a click yeah and
then it'll it'll even you out a little
bit it'll massage it back to normal yeah
it's less gay now
try to shake them off the side yeah
uh all right let's see this one's from
Don Julio 10 Buck here is it garbage to
take a blue chew before you go into a
job interview to have a little
confidence before you go in depends on
the gig you know if you're going into
gay porn yeah take the blue shoe
something you can swing from yeah I work
that's a good I've never taken blue
chill but I assume it puts a little pep
in your step right you feel a little
more yeah but you gotta tell people
you're eating lollipops oh because your
mouth's blue yeah dude yeah that's true
do you get hard immediately no no it
waits it waits until it's activated
until it knows yeah until you watch
those push-up videos
goddamn algorithm it's like Verizon
they resend the signal yeah so uh it
works but you get it's so well made it
knows when you're ready to go right when
you're all when you're right about there
but it does hit you on a vibrate like if
you're on a flight and it's got a little
bumping I mean I'll get one on a plane
anyway oh I'll just cut off the [__]
the humid will get me oh that's why I
don't sit next to you anymore I didn't
know Virgin air
jet Bluetooth ah there it is it should
be linking up
it's a big [__] plane
um
this one's from NED gagansky shout out
to you yeah uh good name well big one
the name Foley came up with
tough one when you're drinking okay
uh we have obviously I would assume you
pee in the shower that's a big topic on
the show ice shark in the shower are you
kidding me all right now this one this
is a caveat to it uh caveat to the peen
in the shower question do you aim for
the drain while peeing in the shower
like a gentleman or do you just let it
fly I uh I never hit the walls I'll say
that it's all bottom okay it's all floor
I'll hit a wall and then I'll splash
water on it to Cascade down to clean to
clean it off because I'm not an animal
at the end of the day right I'm with you
I stand sideways
it's my best size in the shower so I'm
up against the wall and there's
something about putting your hands on
the wall wait where are you facing like
you're getting frisked yeah I'm facing
the wall unless you move officer I've
been a bad boy my shower's up against
the wall so I'll put my hands on the
shower oh and the water will be running
over me and I'll just let go Baby on
like the handle where's the handles what
handles the knobs is that are you like
is your knob high no the knobs are in
front of me so your dick's on the faucet
no so that it's coming this way hold on
ready oh it's not a bath this yeah it is
a bath oh it is so this is the bath here
here's the only you can confuse a room
full of people here's the shower I'm I'm
wait where's the the shower Comes This
Way okay and the nozzles are there you
you know that's facing forward I turned
sideways ah and I I'm up against the
wall and then you pee on the wall and I
just kind of let go whoa it's a
fantastic feeling this looks like you're
flying wow what
from the guy who's clearly never been
flying it does it's like the water's
rushing over you the water's coming at
you I feel like you're one with the
universe that's nice it's not I'm
telling you try it out it's nice it's
all one flow so the urine goes with the
water yes I like it yeah and then I'll
yeah then I'll make sure it gets off man
you're like Ray Liotta yeah
[Laughter]
um I told him I'll tell you I I did get
in trouble a couple months ago where I
kind of started getting see I was
getting I was getting my I was getting
my chops busted for peeing on the
forgetting pee on the floor ah so but
now we have like this little Swiffer
thing that I just do if if it happens
but I kind of got into the mode of just
going into the bathroom to pee and just
peeing in the tub oh wow
but if I'm in the water yeah afterwards
yeah that's a no that's he has done it
before but he doesn't that's how I got
caught uh I got caught because it's It's
gotta smell like [__] Yankee Stadium
no it's not they're starting to be
little stains a little yellow yeah oh
are we just gonna gloss over the piss
Swiffer dude yeah I mean yeah we need
one in here dude every day there's about
four ounces of pee on that in that first
bathroom are you doing the seat up at
least yeah of course I don't do that I
gotta aim yeah it's an ego thing I'm
like I got it
yeah what about when you stop it doesn't
get a little bit
it's pretty good pretty good flow you
gotta be over it you can't stand back
otherwise just physics you'll you'll get
on it yeah you gotta be at it exactly
you gotta be real up on her and then you
gotta jiggle but jiggle to not a too
much gently yes what about a sink piss
done it I've done it like a party
College [__] up or whatever I'm not
gonna you know I've done kitchen sink
before me too yeah when somebody was in
there and I really had to go same man
that's like that's like a [__] bank
robbery oh the clock is ticking yeah you
got that right if my if anybody ever saw
it what the [__] are you doing yeah they
would freak out yeah that's I mean you
can't pinch it either nobody wants to
pinch
ah no that's too painful yeah no you
can't do that oh that's the worst thing
ever no trying to stop peeing halfway
through peeing the worst oh my God tell
that to R Kelly but what about the uh
the Gatorade bottle
yeah I've used okay of course but I
don't have to skill to do it while I'm
driving and that's tough too because
that angle ain't great because you can
only fill up
because if the bottle's like sideway
like if you're sitting yeah it's like
that so it gets starts you can only fill
it up like creeping back you can only
spill it up halfway until you so yeah
it's a very especially if you're driving
and let me tell you something if that
starts to [__] go and it has a lot of
trouble yeah the anxiety is is going up
oh I remember when I was in Philly it
was late at night
you know whatever and I had to pay on
the way home from the Raven lounge and I
made it like [__] yeah I was like 15
minutes from home was pouring rain I'm
like I'm just gonna pee in this Wawa
parking lot because they wouldn't let me
use the bathroom and it was that
happened yeah and it spilled all over
all over my front seat all over my pants
I had about two tree 18 beers in me too
yeah I was like this is tomorrow
morning's probably well you pull over on
the side of the highway and take a leak
all the time I find peeing Outdoors just
literating yeah the best yeah I'll go I
got a backyard in Brooklyn I'm I'm
excited to piss all over oh it's the
best I do it at my mom's all the time
where you guys at on above ground pool
he's got one oh yeah yeah they're quite
trashy although I I also just bought a I
just purchased a property myself uh and
we're talking pool above ground
money why you know I'm telling you man
let's because it's not gonna be it's not
gonna be like I'm not moving there it's
in Pennsylvania so it'll be a place like
we use like when you know for whatever
just to get out of the city and stuff
sure and uh it's like do I dump a [__]
ton of do I take a loan out to put a
[__] in-ground pool in and then you
gotta you gotta have the pH balance or
algae or do I just spend about six G's
at Walmart and get a [__] above
ground pool right and be [__]
partying we have a solid one that we've
had that we've had I've never seen
anything like that what yeah it's huge
it's like it's you're thinking above
ground pool like one that has like the
PVC pipe yeah the big blue just slap one
up okay but some guys have been a deck
and [__] his whole backyard is a deck
it's the the above the biggest it's the
biggest in-ground pool I've ever seen
send me a photo later bigger than most
pools it's a rich it's a real pool it's
not one of the ones that you just get at
Walmart and throw it up oh really no but
I'll say something about this this is my
thought on the above ground pool please
I well first of all is and is an
in-ground pool an option at your house
in Brooklyn no that would be crazy crazy
yeah they probably won't let you yeah
and it's just not that big of a backyard
you'd be hanging you'd probably go down
to the [__] Subway or something end
up on the day train that's true yeah but
on hot days
it's much cooler to get into the above
ground pool than it is an in-ground pool
they they get hot as [__] in the summer
that's true and that that uh what though
cement around it too the in-ground pools
no yes you're wrong I am Telling You
above ground pools get warmer no yes
they do they're much more refreshing
this is uh but this is [__] white
trash [__] I have an above ground
pool and I'm insecure of it so you've
done this a bunch we got a little shade
yeah that tree back there an in-ground
pool is better for sure that thing's out
of direct sunlight
um
you're gonna need the cold plunge how's
the maintenance on that thing I don't
know nothing too nothing too bad you got
a pool guy yeah uh I don't want him
[__] my wife
all right this is all good stuff but I
think I might just change the pool
thinks he's got a shot yeah it's not a
it's not a huge backyard so I might just
get the big blue inflatable just as like
a wading pool I hey in the summer yeah
cool yourself off wrong with it just a
dip you slapping a grill out there oh
you better believe it what you know what
do you have one in mind or you're just
gonna get like a whatever send me links
folks split them up now when you get in
there and get situated and settled is
all the
take out all that stuff can all go away
you know the ordering out and stuff like
that well I don't do it that much to me
it's a real treat because you know I
know guys who do it every meal and I
think that's gluttonous that's too much
you can't live like that you gotta go
hunt a little okay sure so yeah she'll
be cooking up a storm and uh I'm a big
grocery guy are you yeah wearing camo
and key Foods
exactly I hunt for my steel cut oats
oh yeah that's what the whole produce is
for yeah he's a known Thief not to
mention the hot bar that hot bar doesn't
stand a chance with these Sticky Fingers
you can just put like chicken and pasta
in the bowl you just eating and eating
and shopping
yeah no you're not you're not wrong
that's what Whole Foods is I go in there
I eat a cup of soup I leave
I thought everybody did that uh you and
other homeless people I'm sure yeah all
right well they keep the eye on the
hobos and I'm sitting pretty let's just
wear a nice shirt I got a mouthful of
chicken noodle
I'm over the hot bar in the cities I
used to go to the ones in the delis a
lot yeah I'm surprised you're still
rolling the dice on them dude the
pandemic really shook me on those and I
because I was Stacey they're like open
air they're like open air Moroccan
[__] yeah bazaars there's a couple of
flies on them but if you go after four
they lie they knock half the price off
oh yeah because there's double the
bacteria exactly I mean those veggies
are hurting you know they're like
they're dead I saw the guy a homeless
guy once got that film on the meatloaf
that film is flavor
was like I am I never thought I thought
I was like I'm done that has to be
happening 10 times a day at every
hospital we talk about it a lot but the
the bodega ones yeah pre-pandemic a good
[__] well-run tight run [__] that's
alive we're really something else but
that weight adds up of course yeah yeah
you have to know going into it like this
hey it's three meatballs and a two
strings of green beans [__] too oh
really what do you mean those guys ran
Empires that's true but I feel like you
go I think they give you some BuyBacks
like you put three meatballs on the
thing and you eat one you know you can
do a little give and take all right I'll
let you have it he's always looking for
an edge this guy which I respect you
gotta survive it's in the it's in the
wiring the cement is dry
with the French immersion
exactly uh
this one's from code this is funny have
you ever interrupted a live broadcast to
yell High mom into the camera
buoy type thing too wasn't that it yo
baba boo yeah oh yeah I could see you
doing that local news yeah as a kid
skateboarding up yeah you see the guy
there's a dead body there's the lady
reporting and you go hey Bob
I thought everybody did that you know
what it does another big one this is
back in the 80s is uh there was a like a
what do you call it like a Radio Shack
and they had a TV in the front of the
store like in the window with a camera
on the sidewalk you're walking by holy
[__] on the big screen tap dancing but
you're trying to catch yourself at the
camera and on TV you're trying to see
yourself on TV but you're looking at the
camera exactly I think you'll catch it
real quick yeah you get Whiplash yeah
those are all right man
you know pre-phone now everybody's on
Tick Tock and [__] filming themselves
sure I like when they had like the old
karaoke machine or Radio Shack you belt
had a couple of tunes oh yeah play the
electronic drums a little bit hit the
keyboard get the hell out of it oh you
know it was big you go to like a Best
Buy or whatever Circuit City and uh they
had the video game out and if you were
good at that video game you wanted
people to be like I want you to step
right yeah
yes exactly they [__] those up though
they always broke the Sim kid always
broke the controller every time did you
ever play when they had the Xbox at
McDonald's
whoa this is what's like a speed ball
yeah McDonald's and video games yeah
they had a they had like a tower and
they had the the control was sticking
out and it was behind like a like two
inches of glass I don't remember that
T-Bone you know what I'm talking about
no give it a goo they for sure unless
there was some fever dream I had I think
you got like a McDonald's membership or
some [__] you're allowed to go right
this way Mr Foley yeah did you go into
the lounge The Velvet Rope opens up
grimace's guarding the door it's got a
piece on them
they didn't see four Bingo there you go
I still say it's my favorite made my
favorite I can't believe you guys don't
know about this I had no idea I did love
N64 dude Wave Race cruising World USA
GoldenEye Mario Kart Donkey Kong crash
bandico or no some Sly Fox or something
was on there was a bunch of Star Fox
yeah that was all right that was my cup
of tea cruising USA was the best the
best man that guy couldn't tell that guy
nothing that also had blonde convertible
oh just zipping around not a care in the
world
put it right in my ass played it she
plays where the shades oh yeah
God damn we got weird Heroes
healing muscles and like a tight shirt
oh yeah
yeah do a good job that game will be
very different today cruising USA N64
hit for me at like that age pre real
boozing smoking like and like sleepover
so we would just stay up and play
cruising USA or GoldenEye oh yeah for
like [__] 10 hours you know what I
mean of course before you were like into
[__] you're trying to get laid or
drinking or smoking or anything yeah
sure you don't always play video games
we did a big thing where it was like
Pepsi Doritos video games and we would
call radio stations and request so we'd
like put on 311 and we were like we got
it on and we would high five that was
big entertainment now do you think that
there was probably that wasn't your
actual request right there was probably
70 other kids calling to request the
most popular 311 song probably that's my
take on it yeah but you know it'd be
four in the morning true true sometimes
they give you like a Hey [__] Joe
says you know they give you the shout
out to throw out a nickname you know hey
Coke machine says uh put on
but on Green Day uh-huh let me ask you
this I've been asking people not a lot
of people remember do you remember DJ
Delilah no you don't yeah I like the
comments everybody knows it but no guest
or myself know what it is you called she
would tell the breakup stories or like
someone's missing somebody
there you go it's kind of like a
Sleepless in Seattle exactly I think I
didn't know her name but I know what
you're talking about Delilah huh yeah it
did the overnights she had the sultry
voice sultry yeah I got this there we go
finally there you go you got one I got
one and I'm pretty sure he's lying to
you no I remember that but they were
always kind of sad you know there's
always some lady in Vermont who lost her
husband and she can't you know get hard
or whatever it was she wants to hear a
little Air Supply yeah I'd get back on
the right track a little finger popping
in the shower
um this one is first of all do you have
a go-to karaoke song Oh this is how we
do it by Montell Jordan
okay all right that's all right this
guy's is the case is from the cable boys
is it trash to sing the Star-Spangled
Banner at karaoke it's a little weird
it's Gotta unite the crowd though I mean
depending on where you are in America if
you're in like Kansas or something they
did that before the capital Riot they
went to a bar saying that
no I don't think he's got out of hand is
uh that Sinead O'Connor uh nothing
compares to you that's a great tune if
you belt that out yeah oh yeah huh to
you
I won't do it seems a little sad yeah
but you know sometimes you got to bring
the emotion well Sweet Home Alabama is
more of my alley ah okay get everybody
going something all the kids know the
lyrics something to sing along to yeah I
want to feel something
we went to uh we went to a karaoke place
in the Lower East Side and there were
these two kids that were like
giving it their all and man
my cousin was drunk and she was like who
the [__] put this on [__] kids kids
up there belt in his heart out it's
Norman singing Sinead O'Connor I don't
get though unless they go to these rooms
like these karaoke rooms and you have
all your friends in there and you sing
I'm like this feels like a torture thing
it's I've only I've only been in that
once or twice and it's not fun no it's
like you can hang and there's beers and
there's drinking but it's like you gotta
show up [__] up to that yeah and you
should be doing blow in that room too
because the door's closed sure otherwise
you'd just be in a bar sing along with
the music good point yeah they go from
start at zero in that the first 45
minutes especially if it's like you know
Mixed Company it's a weird house yeah
you know what I mean like you're nervous
you don't want to blow it then somebody
goes up there and sings One good you
don't want to [__] look like an idiot
it's a weird one it's like an eighth
grade dance exactly you gotta be
hammered hammered and then Kathy from
accounting is trying to belt out Whitney
it ain't working yeah
take rocks with all that
uh all right let's do a couple more here
this one's from James uh ten dollar
homie is it garbage I have an uncle who
drinks rubbing alcohol when he runs out
of vodka yeah whoa that's a problem
this guy needs to get help I mean I like
a nice cocktail from time to time yeah
was he at that meeting at the strip club
because he needs to be [__] yeah that's
yeah tell that guy to get help that's a
lot rubbing elk I didn't know we could
do that oh you can't yeah yeah you have
to cut that no that's what Betty Ford
did Betty Ford who did that of the
clinic yes whoa wait she did it it was
Gerald Ford's wife yeah but I thought
did she ladybird Ford whatever her name
well she was he drunk or was he drunk no
she was she was she she was an alcoholic
and then started the Betty Ford Clinic
when she got straightened out right
T-Bone good for her but she was slamming
alcohol yeah I'm just I was looking up
what happens if you drink rubbing
alcohol I'm sure they get [__] up yeah
I mean all you do is puke blood oh all
right not so bad been there Listerine
too
whoa I had kids in high school did that
yeah getting Lister Twisted Ah that's
yeah you shouldn't do that either no
dirt ball immersion is cool yeah right
how to be a dirt bag
uh in a little in a more fun boozing
thing this is from this poor guy that's
like brought down the room yeah Jesus
Christ
I got some cuts on my inside this is
garbage if your uncle dies are ferocious
uh this one's from tutorowski and
Associates ten dollar time shareholder
ever use a pool noodle as a beer bong oh
you've never done that no I never
thought to do it man that's a good
[__] time in the pool have you ever
been spit on by somebody with a pool
noodle of course yeah mostly the foam
after the beer bongs
yeah no that's a good time because you
can kind of do them underwater too you
can take it down it's like yeah no I
think yeah that was in college my buddy
had a pool and that was like you know
that was like throwing The Keg in the
pool and stuff the pool noodle came out
when you guys were kids I think because
we didn't have that [__] in the 80s I
was a kid or the well yeah we didn't
know it was late 90s probably yeah mid
mid late 90s talk about something that
hit but really has no [__] use no use
but it was in every goddamn pool yeah
good time you could float on him you
could beat the [__] out of each other
with him you could spit on each other
with them you could do a lot with those
things it just turned violent whenever I
was around of course yeah you just start
beating each other up with them that was
it but to me the raft was the height of
luxury especially if I had a cup holder
of course that was like you know a guy
sunglasses the white nose sunscreen beer
in the raft you were made in the shade
it sucked when you got the raft that was
foam that was yeah
like uh the thing that they'd come in
and get you the Lifeguard would come in
and get you the red thing yeah yeah yeah
not the inflatable no yeah it was almost
like a yoga mat yes those things [__]
blue and they get scalding hot yeah the
only thing good about that was flipping
the guy on it remember you do a little
shark
buddy you could be doing all this next
summer in your brand new pool what the
hell come on by baby well housewarming
would be all right can't wait there you
go uh you're at the age too I mean you
were a skater did you used to skate do
you ever have like uh and someone had a
trampoline and put the decks on the
trail of course yeah that was big that
was a good [__] time we would use
that [__] all we put [__] soap on it
oh you just lived on it yeah as like a
12 year old kid or you just lived on a
trampoline I hooked up with a girl on a
train yeah [__] on a [__] but yeah
great time love a trampoline but now
that they're like illegal no you know
what some people are doing this kind of
cool they're digging them into the
ground whoa so you just step onto it
that's genius I so you don't you don't
fall off so it's an in-ground trampoline
in ground trampoline the classiest of
the trampoline and above grounding
ground and above ground what the
opposite of the pool you got to put the
net on it you have the net but then that
doesn't work I have my three nieces and
nephews that all have broken their arms
or legs on their trampoline that has a
net no kidding oh yes yeah they just get
[__] up I think the net gives you a
false sense of safety yeah you're like I
can do whatever right if you could do
that instead of the pool
just called big trampoline and you got
the big city with the girl out there
yeah that's not bad kind of helps the
hump too if you're on top go big
trampoline you get the double jump
really get the thrust going yeah put a
bounce house out there oh come on come
to creep in a neighborhood I'm not
against the Bell come on in kids I swear
I'm not weird
should I have fun uh it's funny but you
get a hose on a bounce house that's a
good time oh it's fun have you been in a
bounce house as an adult recently not
recently no I wish you did the slip and
slide on uh oh you fully loaded you
getting hit in the nuts I'm sorry but
was a great video did it catch it did it
really catch the nut it somehow missed
my dick and hit all sack
Rose this guy's all stacked the least
athletic guy I've ever met in my life
just humbled Bullseye pull a [__]
perfect Tom Brady spin deflate gate
right into my cons
so you got the feeling I was out I was
out and just laying there the water's
running over me I could taste the dish
soap it was bad yeah I was out for a
good 30. but it was worth it for the
video I hit a million views in like a
day oh [__] yeah but you can't beat a
nutshot I watched it five times yeah we
can write for days and days you'll never
come up with anything funny than a
nutshell that in a fart are all right
and I got Bert doused me with the uh the
ice cold water because it was out of the
ice bag and I was like God damn that was
cold so I was kind of all Jarred up from
that so I didn't see it coming so it was
full no protection brutal straight to
the nuts
that's it let's wrap it up on a very
popular streaming Network gang you gotta
check it out it's out right now Mr Mark
Norman buddy we love you to death yeah
man thank you what else you got coming
up you wanna let the folks out there
big tour coming to Europe going all over
Copenhagen Amsterdam Dublin Germany will
you name it Berlin and uh it's all on
the website markdormancomedy.com coming
to your town as well so get a shirt get
a beer and get a laugh buddy we love you
yeah thank you so much for coming and
see us Skippy what do you got for him I
know we added second shows in Toronto
second show in Toronto third show in uh
Chicago get those tickets show in Denver
L.A second show in Denver tickets left
in L.A Philly uh is gonna go we're doing
the Fillmore there that's [__] like
90 sold out get those tickets we're all
over the road get those tickets now
before they're gone gang love you gang
see you next week